let's now go in the second part of this
amazing celebration of Louis on the
David Pakman show - something that is
truly truly going to withstand the test
of time
I believe this is John we are going
again to segment producer an intern John
who did the research and editing on this
describe what we're about to see here is
this the best of lewis is that what
you're calling this well I mean it has
competition in the manner that there's
another video also titled that but
purportedly but I do believe this one
will stand the test of time and I think
this is where is this is what sculpted
is legacy I was basically put in charge
of Louis's legacy and you know a lot of
people their legacy they're remembered
for one thing despite doing many things
such as Bill Clinton maybe yeah comes to
mind and I basically decided that that
one thing is what we should remember
Louis by except there were like three or
four of them yeah we're going to
remember Louis by John's explanation is
completely clear to me I get it I get it
I understand everything he's saying okay
let's now go this is the the best of
louis including people commenting on
Louis's departure including some of the
most interesting comments regarding
Louis's departure let's all watch it
together for the first time for many of
us let's take a look
where would you try to go and what job
would you try to have I like this
question Louis what what's your thought
on this I think I would like to be
somewhere warm
so nowhere with rough winters producer
Louis is going to be departing from the
program city life is just is just not
for van many people don't want you to be
part of the show many people don't want
me to even be part of the show I also
really don't want to deal with winter
the David Pakman show well just don't
want the show to exist at all I really I
really do not like winter
if my kid sees a penis yeah it's or a
nipple it's all over once you were
choked with a belt by a stripper
right yes I especially disliked his
weasel looking Co Oh Morris I really
enjoy Patriot mail and I really like the
repartee between you and your co-host I
may be a ho no but but Lois I don't know
about that wait a minute
how about word confetti the chemistry
between all right hey there it is David
a lazy Democrat who likes to mooch off
the government you can see how much they
enjoy give me your analysis and critique
Lois of this latest creation of mine
fruityloops vomit what happened I mean
was it just that your clothes did fit
and then you got and then you got
pregnant and then they they stopped
fitting really it's just an appalling
and vile display of cultural
appropriation hi David I haven't seen
Warcraft it's getting slammed by critics
and by people I trust you're putting the
emphasis on the wrong syllable you were
like a level 102 healer right
they've stay out of this Lois kept on
saying I was a queer I did I'm sure that
there there is some religious delusion
as well
yeah but the primary motivating factor
here was probably just butt touching
what are you gonna miss about always
very clear concise yeah yeah yes yes
yeah yes yeah yeah yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah damn good thing yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah you know yeah yeah I'm happy for
Canada yeah I mean yeah yeah I like I
like some curves so Lois do you feel
that it is degrading that your
participation in this endeavor is
degrading to women well I know that's
like in awe
maduk inevitable problematic conflict I
think oh my god believe me there are
plenty of women who find me quite
resistible now taking off his david
pakman show hoodie oh and his shirt is
now over his head honestly I think the
first thing I would do is try to make a
friend in a morgue when we first got to
the studio I tripped over a wire and
have the body cremated and I looked on
the ground and I'm like okay well
nothing happened I don't see anything
wrong here of course then so you're
significantly opening yourself up to
risk because now someone knows what
you're doing that's true that's true but
hey you know money talks you know we
said is everything good
she said yeah everything's good to go we
did the whole interview you gotta burn
all the hair off the body and while Dave
could still hear the person he was
interviewing their audio was not
recorded and then the teeth the
fingernails and toenails have to come
off listen that whole 10 15 minute
interview we just did well it didn't
really happen and those have to be
discarded separately in a place where no
one can find them and of course they
were very small can we do that again
please
he had many great views on life I
thought the rule was just I get the
armrest if you're larger
no just no matter what I guess mine
really the human experience as a whole
if someone comes into your place and
makes a mess that that's not good for
anybody yeah yeah I mean if ifs if they
defecate on the floor in your living
room just don't never have them over
again you know I was going through some
hard times and seeing someone with such
a positive outlook was a big help
still every time I get on a plane and
every time there's turbulence your mind
goes to one place trick is when you're
in Vegas - and I've never been to Vegas
this is just what I've picked up they
say they love country music yes so many
of them do you go to a place where they
will give you free drinks for sitting
and playing at the slot machines or
they're wearing a cowboy hat in the
picture but that but they're not from or
have ever been anywhere near where that
would be necessary the idea is that you
get more drunk and and you put more
money into the machines so you sit there
and once every every five minutes you
put a quarter in I don't like that it
might not be a deal breaker because so
many people love country music that have
you how do you get away from that but
you you hand the your server or 20 and
say keep them coming
not even country music anymore it's it's
really just pop but Wow and and then you
get wasted very cheap and you enjoy your
night they call it country because of
southern accents and cowboy hats more
people liking the dog picture however
which leads me to believe that people
generally prefer dogs over babies which
I must say is true in my case
find me one person whose mind has been
changed that's the result of a twitter
battle after the EMP attack yeah you're
probably gonna want DVDs I haven't used
Clippers on my nails in maybe it may be
a decade or more you know between the
two of them I really think Lewis was the
one who had a little bit more fun if you
know what I'm saying
I have done shrooms once whatever we
were smoking must have had something
else in it it was really more of a
physical hi than than a psychedelic one
there was one occasion where I was just
bombed
I didn't I didn't really care I mean a
hat maybe I should have done more
everything was moving in slow motion
I could feel no pain there was one time
where I smoked so much pot and had had a
very low tolerance for it at the same
time that it was an incredibly paranoid
state everything was moving in slow
motion and I could feel no pain it was
coffee coffee that I had poured my
scotch into so I guess you could call it
a cocktail it's no coincidence the
announcement comes around 4:20 and I was
just tricking myself into thinking I was
having a good time and getting pretty
drunk before even arriving and I thought
the cake was wonderful so I just I went
down of course I was I think I was drunk
at that point already and it was it was
one crazy evening I think we can say for
sure it was there there was alcohol
involved
and we'll leave it at that and we'll
leave it at that and we'll leave it at
that
this job is great I love it
I don't want to live in in complete
isolation
my family's here and well my friends are
here
I enjoy doing the show
well I would go with the tennis ball
because I think it would just be easier
to go about your daily life now either
the either way you're gonna be a freak
and the Grandison super-ego
right
the now what I have said is that if I
accidentally had a kid yeah I'd probably
love the kid and things would be great
you would if Louis accidentally had a
kid probably he would love the kid but
he can't really say that's that's the
sense of it isn't it Louis right well
how can I say for sure
amazing Louis and is that would would
you say that that is the the peak moment
to go out on if I accidentally had a kid
I would probably love the kid but you
can't say for sure that that's probably
the moment and I I might call this
instead of the best of Louis the least
worst of Louis but good stuff John was
there anything particularly disturbing
that you came across that did not make
it into this because it was just too
shocking and appalling oh yeah actually
this kind of is a little anecdote I
guess earlier this summer
Louis sneezed and I said bless you once
and then I found a video of him saying
he absolutely hates it when people say
bless you and right after I watched it
he sneezed and it was really awkward
silence it's been an awkward summer
semester for John Anderson but
absolutely fantastic work I mean we did
it must be applauded oh yes no doubt
it's I couldn't have done a better job
myself on the video on today's bonus on
go ahead so what I said according to the
video you're dead so III yeah I couldn't
work on it at all on the bonus show
today we will allow things to calm down
we will talk about an $800 Lord of the
Rings box set and how many of those
Louis will be purchasing on his way out
today comcast has purchased DreamWorks
and some ultra Orthodox rabbis have
banned women from college which is a
pretty common thing in the most
extremist areas of most religions you
certainly don't want educated women if
you want to maintain control as men over
the population david pakman.com slash
membership that's how you sign up